Tom Brady
news reports are out now that even Tom
Brady and his supermodel wife Giselle I
don't know how to pronounce her maiden
name boonjin bungen I don't know his his
very beautiful wife Giselle are
reportedly hiring divorce lawyers and
looking to split up
I'm not all that interested in covering
tabloid stories I'm not all that
interested
I feel very bad for Tom Brady and his
wife and especially for their kids
but this is not just a private matter
sometimes you hear people say oh you
know if a guy's going to get divorced
That's Just A Private Matter stay out of
his private life it's not A Private
Matter
marriage is a public institution that's
why you do it in public
that's why you register it with the
state
and before before you registered it with
the state you would register it with the
church which was frequently established
by the state there has always been a
public component here you take your
marriage vows
not just to your spouse but before God
before some kind of Minister whether
it's a priest or it's a minister of the
a Justice of the Peace
and usually you may take those vows
before your friends and family and the
whole community
at the very least you have to do it
before a witness right even if you go to
the Elvis chapel in Vegas you got to do
it before a witness so this is a public
matter it actually is our business
and it's it's very sad I'm sure these
people are going through a ton of pain
right now
but I think it is our responsibility
as Citizens not be not friends of Tom
Brady I don't know Tom Brady
not as you know people who are in the
family but our responsibility as
Citizens to say
they shouldn't do this
they shouldn't do this I I know it's a
fallen world and people have tough
marriages and people go through rough
patches
I have never seen a family improved by
divorce
sometimes in in very rare cases there is
even there is not only a right but an
obligation to have some kind of
Separation let's say that I don't know
the husband is a knock down violent
abusive drunk and he's thrown his wife
against the walls and sometimes for the
for just the protection of one's own
life and the life of One's Own kids
there is some separation that might be
required
say until the you know the husband goes
to rehab or something like that figures
out his life I'm not I'm not denying
that
but as a rule I have never ever seen a
family improved by divorce
these people I don't know anything about
their circumstances I don't know did
someone cheat on someone did someone I
actually I don't think that's even being
reported right now what's being reported
is that Tom Brady and his wife are
getting divorced or might be getting
divorced because they had an argument
over whether Tom was going to retire
from football or not
and she was upset that he didn't spend
enough time with the kids and she didn't
want to go back to work or whatever
again this is all tabloid trash I have
no idea what's actually going on in the
marriage
and I don't really care
figure it out
figure it out but it doesn't it's not
reparable at this point it's it's
absolutely the marriage is just beyond
repair
no it isn't I I asked before I got
married I was I was asking for marital
advice from lots of people and some of
the best I said how do you avoid getting
divorced 50 of marriages or something
end in divorce right now so many of my
friends and family members their parents
were divorced how do you avoid divorce
how do you keep a marriage together
and and the best advice I heard was very
simple they said oh well the best way to
keep your marriage together and have a
long marriage is just just don't get
divorced just work through it
all marriages are going to go through
rough patches
any two people who spend enough time
together are gonna going to have
disagreements and going to have periods
where they they really don't like one
another but there is something greater
than your individual desires
certainly the kids
interests should come before the
interests of the parents
but the marriage itself is an
institution
and as we weaken marriage culturally
politically legally as we weaken that
the whole country is going to weaken
they they should not get divorced I was
I was
also very taken with the Kim and Kanye
divorce story because you all heard all
these people well he is kind of crazy
and she doesn't like what he's doing and
they disagree over this that uh yeah who
cares Kim Kardashian goes and and she
does an interview with one of the glossy
magazines and she says you know I'm just
not happy right now and I just want to
my 40s are going to be about me no it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be about you
at all and I don't and I don't care if
you don't feel happy at this particular
moment you're not going to feel happy at
every single moment of your life
that's why it's a fallen world
there are more important things than
your
individual pleasure at any given moment
just work it out work it out and this is
I'm giving this commentary not to stick
my nose in Tom Brady's business or
anyone else's business for that matter
I'm doing it because it's it's true
neither of these people will be happier
in the long run if they get divorced
I've never seen it if you're if you're
listening to this and you've been
divorced are you really happier you
really happier do you really think your
life is better because you got divorced
maybe your wife left you maybe your
husband left you maybe it was something
that you really couldn't avoid I I'm not
I'm not casting stones
but on the topic of divorce itself are
you really happier no no I've never met
anyone who could tell me that they're
really happier by that speaking of
pushing these narratives speaking of
everything every single thing becoming
super duper gay
we have got a a trailer for this movie
that my producers insist that I watch
it's called Bros it's a movie it didn't
do very well apparently at the box
office on opening weekend it's
apparently very very gay
they The Producers want to know if I
should review this movie give an actual
proper review we'll take a look at the
trailer together you tell me if we
should review the movie the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]